- Hi, everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our special
Homeroom edition on college,
"Is College Right For Me,"
or I guess is college right for you.
We have a very exciting
group of panelists,
young people who are maybe a few years
ahead of many of y'all who
are expert in several domains,
but especially expert in
thinking about college
when it's right, what
other options there are
and how to make the most of it,
but before we jump into that,
I will give my standard reminders.
First of all, we are a not-for-profit
and if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
It's because of your donations,
if you're in a position to do so,
that make Khan Academy possible to reach
hundreds of millions of
folks around the world.
I also want to give a special shout out
to several organizations that
have gone above and beyond
in supporting Khan Academy,
especially since the seemingly
never ending pandemic started
over a year and a half ago.
A special thanks to Bank of America,
AT&T, Google.org,
Novartis, Fastly, and General Motors,
and the many other
supporters across the board
who have contributed to
Khan Academy to allow
us to do the work that we do.
So, and final announcement,
there is a podcast version
of this live stream
wherever you get your podcasts:
Homeroom with Sal, The Podcast.
So I encourage you to
check that out, as well.
So with that out of the way,
I am super excited to
introduce our panelists
and I will actually ask them
to introduce themselves,
but we have Delisha, who
is a cybersecurity expert
and also recent college grad.
We have Madison, who is a designer artist
associated with CNN+ and
also a recent college grad.
And we have Ernest, who is a
software engineer at Google
and founder and president of Code House,
and also a recent college grad.
But Delisha, let me start with you.
Tell us a little bit about
who you are and your journey
into becoming a cybersecurity expert.
- Yeah, Sal.
Thank you, I'm so glad to be here.
Hi everyone out there.
I am Delisha Hodo,
an undergraduate
cybersecurity student advisor,
as Sal stated.
In my career, I have the
pleasure of advising,
as well as supporting
students and future defenders
in the cybersecurity space.
And in that work, we're making
sure that they are trained
so that they can not only defend our world
in the cybersecurity world,
but also defend you and
the different things
that you love to do.
When I'm not advising, I am the
chair of our Sans HBCU team,
where our goal is to
support juniors and seniors
at historically black
colleges and universities
receive free cybersecurity training
and certifications, as well.
And honestly, what led me to
this path of cybersecurity
was honestly by chance.
I actually majored in psychology,
got my bachelor's in psychology.
And it's one of those
majors where it allows you
to go anywhere and end up anywhere.
And I'm one of those
people that pretty much,
I would say cybersecurity found me
and I wouldn't have it any other way,
as it allows me to watch other students
and other individuals achieve greatness
while also defending the world
from cyber attacks and bad actors,
as well as supporting others and hopefully
inspiring more of you out
there to help us defend
and become cybersecurity experts, as well.
- I love that, Delisha.
And I'm gonna ask you many
more questions about it,
especially because, at
least what you're advising
these undergraduate students to do,
it's like they could get to
live in a Tom Clancy novel.
They get to like defend the country
in the cyber world, which
is obviously only becoming
a bigger and bigger thing,
but let's go to you Ernest.
Tell me a little bit about your journey
and how you ended up both
as a software engineer,
but also what you're doing at Code House.
- Sure.
So thanks for the
introduction, glad to be here.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Ernest Holmes.
I grew up in New Jersey and
I made it all the way down
to Atlanta to attend college
at Morehouse College.
Morehouse College is an
historically Black institution
serving all Black men.
And while at Morehouse,
I was very aware about
the many opportunities
that exist in the tech industry.
And when I was just a freshman,
I actually wound up getting
an internship at Google
to be a software engineer.
So I spent every summer actually
while I was at Morehouse
interning at Google out in California.
So they flew me out,
got to work on amazing
projects from advertisements,
mobile to development,
to artificial intelligence
and machine learning
on these robotic flowers.
And that eventually allowed me to become
a full-time software engineer at Google
working on the fuchsia team.
So that's my day job.
That's what I do, and I'm very passionate
about being in the tech industry,
but I also realized that there was a need
for more people of color to be exposed to,
especially at an earlier age,
to the different opportunities that exist
in the tech industry,
whether it's engineering
or design, product management.
And that allowed me to get together,
not only with my sister,
but one of my best
friends, Travis Thompson,
and the other person on this call,
Madison Metivier, and a bunch of other
great individuals to make Code House,
which is all about
exposing students of color
to the tech industry.
So we expose middle and
high school students
to different careers in the tech industry,
but then now we also support
early college students
with scholarships, that's
right, scholarships.
So we can actually pay for your schooling
if you're interested in
going into tech industry
and attending an HBCU.
So that's a little bit about me,
and I guess the last hat I wear right now,
I'm also actually a professor
at Morehouse College,
teaching freshmen computer science.
So wearing a few different hats right now.
- I want to ask you more
questions about that.
We actually already
have questions coming in
through YouTube.
I encourage anyone watching to
start putting your questions
for any of these very
impressive young people
that you see in front of you.
But I have one question
before I move on to Madison,
what does the fuchsia team work on?
Fuchsia is just a color.
What is the fuchsia team?
(Ernest laughing)
- I'm glad you asked.
Yeah, fuchsia is actually
an operating system
that we're building from
scratch completely open source,
and it's actually one of
the first large developments
of operating systems
that's non Linux-based.
So a little background, every single thing
that works right now, computers, phones,
they're all derived and based
in this thing called Linux.
We decided to make a operating system
that is not based on Linux.
So it's rethinking how computers work
and how eventually different devices
can interact with one another.
Super cool project, super cool team,
and hopefully you see a
lot more fuchsia soon.
- And I'm still wondering how
it's connected to the color,
but maybe we'll get into
that at another point.
But Madison, tell us a
little bit about your journey
on how you got to where you are
as a designer and an artist.
- Yeah well, hey everyone.
Good afternoon, good evening,
good morning wherever you are.
My name is Madison Metivier.
I am a proud and loud 2019
graduate of Howard University,
earning a bachelor's
in fine arts in design
and a double minor in
art history and German.
So that love for art actually brought me
to my current position.
I am a graphic artist, slash
production designer at CNN+.
For those who may not
be familiar with CNN+,
it's totally okay.
It actually launches next year.
It's CNN's streaming platform.
So kind of like an HBO
Max, a Netflix, but CNN.
So what that compiles
is a couple of things
I can't talk about, but very generally
it's a bunch of unique TV programming
that you can access on
a streaming platform.
Well, that's my day job.
After 6:00 PM, I kind of switch hats,
and I'm not only the creative director
at Code House Corporation,
as Ernest so eloquently explained,
but I'm also owner of my own
creative agency, Ojii Creative,
where we work with
brands such as Ruby Rose.
It's been a crazy wild ride
with the amounts of clients
and types from small
businesses to larger ones,
such as Quality Control
Music, Universal Music Group,
as well as community
centers in the Dallas area.
And yeah, my love of art
really brought me here
to be quite honest with you.
- That's incredible.
You know, I'd like to think that I was
doing pretty well for
myself in my early twenties,
but y'all are making me
feel somewhat insecure
about what I was doing with myself,
given all that y'all have
already accomplished,
but the topic of today is
College, Is It Right For Me,
or is it right for the folks listening?
And you can imagine there's
a lot of young people,
some of whom are are saying,
"I want to go to college".
Some folks are saying, "I'm not sure.
"There might be other paths."
And then even amongst the people
who are thinking about
college, they're saying,
"Can I afford it?
"How do I figure out how to navigate it?
"What types of colleges
should I go through?"
So I'd like to go one by one,
three all again, and say,
how were you thinking about it
when you were 16 or 17 years old?
Did you have some of these doubts?
How did you navigate these doubts?
Was it random chance?
Were there certain things you did
that helped you make better decisions?
And actually I'll go to the same order.
Delisha, I'll start with you.
- Yeah, for me, I was a first gen,
so first in my family to actually
attend college and graduate.
So for me, it was a lot of
exploration, a lot of thinking.
I initially actually wanted
to go into audio engineering,
so leaning into music
production because I love music
and I'm a very creative person.
And I soon discovered, and it's something
that you're gonna speak about
and you spoke a little bit to,
that financial piece.
I sadly discovered that financially
the school wasn't a fit for me
and I wasn't gonna be able
to go into audio engineering.
So that's when I made that
pivot to my plan B, psychology,
and haven't looked back since.
But for me I'll say, it's a unique path,
especially if you are a future
first-generation student
out there in the world and
you're the first in your family,
there's a lot of resources out there.
There's a lot of people
that you can lean on.
And what I will say to you is
life is not a straight path.
So don't be worried if you do not end up
in a career in your major.
That's pretty normal right now
in the world that we live in.
But that doesn't mean
that you're a failure.
What it means is you were
brave enough to take a chance
and that you still have
light years ahead of you
to discover what your passion is
and to do something that makes you happy.
- And to make sure I understand,
you were originally thinking
about audio engineering
and you decided to move out of that
because it was at a different school
and that was too expensive,
or you were thinking that the career
might be harder to attain?
How did make that transition.
- Initially, 'cause I'm
in the state of Georgia,
there was only one college
that actually offered
anything near to audio engineering,
and that college was Savannah
College of Art and Design.
It's a private college, so with that,
it was extremely expensive,
and again, as I said before,
I'm first gen, first in my family.
We're not the richest in the world.
So when I received that
financial aid package,
I realized, "Wow, even with a scholarship,
"I can't afford $30,000 a
year or however much it was."
So I had to make that
conscious decision to say,
"You know what, I do like
psychology, so let me pivot.
"My plan B is gonna be I'm
gonna pivot to psychology.
"I'm gonna see where it takes me,
"and if it's meant to be, I'll always find
"my way back to music,
whether it's through
"audio engineering or just
finding ways to express myself
"in other ways, whether through
spoken word, which I do,
"poetry, or just enjoying
listening to music
"and analyzing it."
So you can still find those joys
without necessarily going
into that major or career.
So that's kind of how I was able to pivot
and change my mindset about it.
And quite frankly, didn't
really have a choice
because of the financial situation,
but I feel like at the end of
the day, looking back on it,
it was the right choice to
make and not go into debt,
as much debt doing that.
And as always, because I'm still young,
if I really want it to go
back into audio engineering,
I'm sure I could.
- No, and thanks for sharing that story
because I think students don't
hear those stories enough,
because so many times in a forum like this
people are like, "Oh,
just do whatever you want
"and all of that" and
there are students saying,
"But how am I gonna pay for that?"
I remember being in a similar situation.
My family, we grew up
not a lot of resources.
And I remember my sister
applying to a school
but I'm like, "How are we gonna pay for,"
and I think at the time,
this was in the '90s,
it was $25,000 a year.
I was like, "That's
more than my mom makes.
"That's twice what my mom makes in a year.
"How are we going to do that?"
And then my sister explained to me
about the whole financial
aid system and all of that.
So to your story, it sounds like,
it sounds like you did the right things.
You said, "What am I interested in?"
But you'll explore the options.
You said, "Okay, now
what are they offering?"
They might be offering a
little bit of scholarship,
a little bit of financial aid,
but it still was not practical,
but there's other really good options.
And obviously now you
are helping other people
defend our country against cyber threats
and whatever else.
Ernest, how did you think about
this when you were 16 or 17?
Did you always know you were going to be
a software engineer?
Did you always know you
were going to go to college?
Did you always think it
was going to be Morehouse?
How do you navigate that?